or dr. David agus is in Los Angeles
following the latest developments in the
corona virus outbreak David good morning
good morning Anthony that we the number
of corona virus cases as has nearly
tripled in just a week so how would we
should we consider the risk to be at
this point
well I'm realized that part of the
reason is going up pretty dramatically
is that for the first time now we're
testing we have some tests we don't have
enough tests
tests are still being distributed across
the country until yesterday afternoon
you had to be hospitalized with symptoms
to get a test and so we haven't tested
most people that being said it is still
relatively low risk for anybody having a
complication from a corona virus in this
country it will happen but it's a very
low rate the virus seems to be spreading
more quickly here is it it's certainly
spreading quickly right every person
with it can spread to other people so
it's what we call exponential spread so
the more people have it the more people
will have it it will keep going and
we're starting to see that now we're
starting to see schools closed offices
say work from home and those sorts of
quarantine measures are what's quite
required to stop the virus and they're
happening as we speak
doctor in South Korea they are testing
people at drive-through stations where
people get their their temperature taken
could we see that kind of wide scale
testing here in the US well this is it's
brilliant right is that most people
don't want to go to an emergency room
and sit there for three hours and be
tested where other people are coughing
if they don't have the virus and when
they went in they may have it when they
went out in South Korea you get in your
car drive they test you and then they
tell you later in the day what happened
that certainly makes sense to me and
those kind of systems the United States
I think would actually change the
numerator you know the problem is we
don't know the death rate in our country
or around the world because we don't
know who has the virus so if you change
the numerator that is the number of
people being tested we can get real data
enact policy and have leadership when it
comes to stopping the spread of the the
virus some other countries have very
specific recommendations like in Israel
they're saying don't touch the little
prayer thing on the doorway in in France
they're saying don't kiss on the cheek
so low we don't have that level of
specific recommendation here from this
DDC why is that well because we don't
kiss people on the cheek like in France
things that mean should we not be
shaking hands should we not be gathering
in groups of 12 percent we need
leadership here and we need to change
our interactions you know when you touch
somebody obviously that's a potential
for spread a virus the government needs
to step up we need transparency on data
we need to know how many tests are being
done in each city and what is the
positive rate in each area we need to
know how many tests are available we
need to know behavior change
modifications each of us need to make to
get normative behavior changed you need
leadership and we need that's badly in
this country I know I think Tony raises
a good point I went to see West Side
Story last night saw a friend ran into a
friend he said is it okay to hug I go I
think so but I mean I really don't know
the answer to any of these questions I
think we all have to use an abundance of
caution and you know it's not
necessarily for ourselves but it maybe
it's our elderly parents maybe it's our
neighbor who's 85 years old or the
neighbor two houses down who has breast
cancer is getting treatment we all have
to look out for each other it's a new
era in our country and it's an era of
community David a vaccine is at least a
year away where do we actually stand on
treating this well yeah all right a
vaccine is at least a year away 18
months probably the soon as if at all we
have drugs that we think may work and
they're being tested now in clinical
trials in Nebraska and in Europe some of
those drugs are already on the market
for HIV and influenza others are newer
drugs meant for those diseases but work
against this one some of the mechanisms
to allow the virus to divide are the
same among viruses and so there's
certainly encouragement that these drugs
will work we should have that data over
the next several weeks is there a
question out there Oh David that you are
still wondering about that needs to be
answered I know very little about this
virus I don't know it's infectivity rate
so I don't know exactly how its
transmitted I don't know how long
someone is infectious I don't know if
someone gets an infection
a year later can they get a reinfection
with this virus those are all unanswered
questions you know when you have the
head of the World Health Organization
say I'm not really sure what's going on
to me that's a very scary moment the
scientific community the leadership and
politic needs to get together and start
to say here are the
we need answer and to divvy it up and
all of us together come up with answers
all right dr. David Eggers thank you
very much
you